en el vídeo donde primero introducimos
el concepto de entropía simplemente
tratamos de definir el cambio en la
entropía como vamos a definir el cambio
en la entropía igual al calor agregado
al sistema dividido por la temperatura a
la cual fue agregado verdad y cuando
tratamos de ver si es una variable de
estado validad lo hacíamos de hecho en
un ciclo de carlos verdad por ejemplo si
ponemos aquí vamos a hacer un pequeño
repaso si tenemos aquí nuestro diagrama
de presión volumen entonces tenemos un
estado inicial aquí digamos y nos vamos
de forma isotérmica nos vamos moviendo
quitando piedritas granitos así
incrementamos el volumen y bajamos la
presión
ok todo esto nos movemos de forma
isotérmica y luego bajamos de forma ad
diabética verdad a algún otro estado
igual seguimos quitando granitos después
los vamos agregando nuevamente de forma
hizo térmica
y volvemos a aislar el sistema para
regresar al punto inicial de forma
diabética verdad este es el repaso
pequeño de un ciclo de carnota y aquí
agrega vamos calor en la en la primera
parte
aquí agregamos y lo dejábamos a
temperatura de uno de este lado lo
dejábamos a temperatura de dos y esto
era porque agregamos un calor con uno y
también se liberaba un calor q2
en esta segunda sección y como eran
procesos a diabéticos los de digamos los
extremos izquierdo y derecho no había
pérdida de energía en ese sentido y así
podíamos definir la entropía o más bien
el cambio total en esta variable s que
es la entropía y al recorrer todo el
ciclo de carnota resultaba que el cambio
en realidad era 1 / t 1 + q 2 sobre t 2
y de hecho les demostré que este era
igual a 0 verdad a lo largo de este
ciclo y que da el resultado que quería
ver porque para que esto sea una
variable de estado ese bebé no debe
depender de otra cosa más que su
posición en este diagrama ok así que
aunque hiciera yo una trayectoria muy
loca al final si regreso al mismo punto
debería obtener que el cambio fue cero
pero hice algo supuse algo muy ligero
que de hecho no estaba tan claro en la
demostración pero lo que hice en la
demostración para que esto sea una
variable de estado a lo largo del ciclo
de carnota esto es válido simplemente
porque el ciclo era reversible entonces
debería poner aquí irreversible este es
un punto super importante que debe
clarificar en el vídeo anterior pero
bueno creo que estaba tan emocionado
haciendo la demostración que realmente
lo di por lo lo pasé por alto entonces
quiero que repasemos un poquito lo que
significa la
civilidad y entonces sabemos que si
definimos una trayectoria aquí por
ejemplo el sistema el sistema debe estar
muy cerca siempre el equilibrio para que
podamos hacer todo esto de lo que
estamos hablando verdad si tenemos
nuestro sistema con el pistón y cómo lo
hemos visto ya muchas veces si ponemos
aquí por ejemplo piedritas o arena o qué
sé yo si vamos haciendo cambios
realmente pequeños vamos llegar nos
mantenemos en un proceso casi estático
verdad es un proceso cuasi estático y ya
lo habíamos definido antes un proceso
cuasi estático y eso significa que
siempre estamos cerca de un casi
equilibrio una cuasi equilibrio es decir
el equilibrio se va moviendo pero nos
mantenemos en un estado de equilibrio
para que podamos definir estas variables
ok
además suponemos que no hay fricción
no hay fricción y de esta forma
garantizamos que sea reversible verdad
porque significa que bueno como vimos en
los vídeos anteriores que si yo hago que
el pistón se mueva por ejemplo baje o
suba cuando el pistón se mueve en
realidad se digamos que choca con la
pared del cilindro verdad entonces se
pierde calor a través de fricción cuando
empezamos a hacer que el pistón se mueva
ok si está por ejemplo arrastrándose
digamos choca con las paredes del
cilindro en realidad se pierde cierto
calor generado por la presión en si
quitamos por ejemplo un granito una
piedrita cuando quitamos esa primera
podría no ocurrir nada pero a medida que
vamos moviendo y moviendo en realidad
hay una fuerza ejercida por la fricción
y que hace que se pierda calor entonces
al quitar granitos este pistón sube un
poco y debido a que bueno podemos pensar
que la diferencial de fuerza o de
presión entre el gas que está dentro y
la presión ejercida por los granitos
en realidad ese diferencial se genera
genera calor opuesta al trabajo verdad
es decir no vamos a regresar de la misma
forma al agregar granitos porque la
fricción siempre se resiste el
movimiento así que para poder obtener
algo de forma reversible cuando quitó un
par de granitos entonces a lo mejor
puede que para regresar al mismo punto
tengo que agregar 10 granitos pero bueno
si hay fricción esto no va a regresar al
mismo estado exactamente mi pistón no se
va a mover tanto como esperaría yo sin
fricción así que una clave para la
reversibilidad es que no haya fricción
ahora el ciclo de kart no por definición
es reversible baja por definición y por
eso uno podría realmente implementar una
máquina que funcione como como el ciclo
de carnet más bien no podemos no
podríamos encontrar una verdad porque el
ciclo de carne es el es la máquina de
más eficiente si alguien pudiera generar
una máquina de carne realmente tendría
movimiento perpetuo una máquina de
energía
perpetua y la razón por la cual en la
máquina de carne no hay secreto en esto
funciona es porque se supone que es sin
fricción
si podemos remover la fricción de todo
el sistema tendría más tendríamos algo
muy eficiente ahora con esto dicho ya
que es la que hemos hecho este repaso la
definición no tiene que ser bueno en
realidad la definición del cambio de la
entropía vamos a suponer digamos ahorita
que no tenemos un proceso de reversible
y vamos a demostrar que realmente no
podemos definirlo como tal así que
digamos que tenemos otro diagrama de
presión volumen vamos a hacer algo muy
parecido a lo que ya habíamos hecho
anteriormente vamos a hacer como un
experimento mental y vamos a tener ahora
un sistema irreversible
ok tenemos un punto en el en el diagrama
y digamos ya sabes un algún tipo de
cilindro que tiene un pistón arriba y
tengo las rocas como siempre
pero en esta ocasión vamos a poner tanta
fricción cuando el pistón se mueve
genera cierta resistencia al movimiento
por fricción o que entonces se genera
cierto calor que vamos a llamar calor
por fricción y cuando ya sea cuando se
mueve arriba o hacia abajo así que vamos
a hacer lo siguiente vamos a anclar este
esto a un depósito digamos que lo
mantiene una temperatura de 1 y vamos a
empezar a remover granitos de arena y
vamos a movernos a lo largo de una curva
isoterma ok ahí está nuestra curva
isoterma quizás llegamos a un punto aquí
y después vamos a dejar de gmail déjenme
ponerlo así de digamos que como esto
tiene fricción esto realmente va a
llegar a un punto no a donde no tenía
fricción sino quizás más adelante verdad
ok a lo largo de éste isoterma así que
el número de rocas no va a ser las
mismas que tengo que remover como si no
tuviera fricción es otro punto y después
empezamos a regar las
las piedritas asia para regresar en el
proceso pero vamos a tener que agregar
un número diferente de rocas o de
granitos verdad quizás si agregamos el
mismo número de que quitamos no regresó
al punto inicial pero bueno tendré que
agregar muchas más piedritas en este
caso el cambio en la energía total será
igual a cero jaja y que será igual al
cambio en la energía de expansión a este
digamos el cambio en la energía de la
expansión más el cambio de la energía de
contracción es decir cuando nos vamos
hacia atrás esos tienen que ser cero
verdad para que la energía interna sea
una variable bien definida una macro
estado así que nuestra delta tiene que
ser igual a cero ok pero quién es la
delta de la expansión es decir cuál es
el cambio en la energía si nos
expandimos ok del tau de la expansión es
igual al calor agregado al sistema
el calor agregado al sistema - - el
trabajo realizado por el sistema
entonces le quitamos el trabajo
realizado por el sistema y ya sabemos
que el trabajo es el área debajo de la
curva y después agregamos el calor
agregado por la fricción baja es decir
déjenme ponerlo esto en otro color este
es el calor de la fricción y hoy ustedes
oyeron eso es que estaba en una página
web fuera de la pantalla rara no sé de
repente una caricatura empezó a sonar no
tenía idea de qué era pero bueno dónde
estaba decíamos que nuestro cambio en la
energía interna por la expansión era el
calor agregado al sistema menos el
trabajo realizado por el sistema y
mientras se había expansión más el calor
agregado al sistema o generado por el
sistema digamos
podríamos decir que realmente el sistema
está creando este calor el mismo verdad
mientras se expande y ese es el calor de
la fricción muy bien entonces es la
única variación que teníamos respecto al
problema anterior y ahora vamos a ver
cuál es el cambio en la energía por la
contracción ok y esto va a ser igual eso
va a ser digamos el calor que sale del
sistema que ya ven que poníamos en un
depósito en donde era frío realmente
entonces libera damos calor el calor se
liberaba entonces vamos a suponer que
las q son positivas entonces lo puedo
poner como menos menos el calor que se
libera suponiendo que la q es es de un
número positivo verdad de esta forma así
con el menos podemos garantizar que se
está liberando espero que esto haga las
cosas un poquito más claros más el
trabajo realizado hacia el sistema de
verdad porque estamos suponiendo que si
hacemos el trabajo realizado por el
sistema es con menos pero si nosotros le
aplicamos trabajo lleva aún más y
seguimos agregando el calor generado por
la fricción en cualquier dirección si
nos movemos
hacia arriba o hacia abajo el sistema
sigue generando fricción ahora como ya
hemos dicho hasta este punto es decir si
la suma de estos tiene que ser igual a
cero porque es el cambio la energía
interna ok entonces esta suma debe ser
igual a cero y eso nos queda que cuba
menos q r
se cancelan las dobles aquí estas dobles
se cancelan y hay que sumar déjenme
cambiar de color hay que sumar dos veces
q efe el calor generado por la fricción
ok en cualquier dirección y eso tiene
que ser igual a cero para que la energía
interna sea una un macro estado ahora
podemos esto reescribirlo como cual
menos q r igual a menos 2 q
efe que es la cantidad de calor generado
por la fricción y luego simplemente
cambiamos el signo de ambos lados y nos
queda qr menos q a es igual a
efe 2 efe ahora porque hice todo esto
porque lo que quiero hacer es un
experimento con con este sistema
irreversible y esto es un experimento
muy sencillo muy sencillo porque
habíamos dicho que mi delta ese a lo
largo digamos en realidad lo definía
como q / t verdad cuando era reversible
lo que quiero mostrarles ahora es que si
defino en la delta s de esta forma para
un proceso irreversible entonces esto no
va a poder ser no nos va a definir una
variable de estado y vamos a verlo así
porque si dividimos ambos lados por t
que sólo lo dividimos todo por t
dividimos todo porte ok que es nuestra
digamos que si suponemos que la
temperatura es constante todo el tiempo
digamos esto del lado izquierdo es
nuestra delta s
este es nuestro cambio en bueno lo que
podríamos entender como entropía que
vamos a ver que no es eso porque no es
cero y de hecho si se dan cuenta del
lado derecho nos queda que es algo que
es distinto de cero esto es el calor
agregado al sistema dividido por la
temperatura a la cual fue agregado
entonces entonces tenemos finalmente que
esto es un número positivo así que
aunque estemos en el mismo punto al no
ser reversible el sistema entonces esto
no es una variable de estado válida
verdad porque no fue cero fue algo
estrictamente positivo ahora eso no
significa que no podamos hablar de la
entropía en reacciones irreversibles
podemos hablar de la entropía en
cualquier caso verdad pero este es un
punto un poquito
distinto es importante digamos que tengo
una reacción irreversible
ok que va por ejemplo de este estado a
este otro y qué sigue
hoy quiero entender cuál es el cambio en
la entropía y digamos que la reacción
irreversible hace una trayectoria muy
loca cómo está suponiendo que es cuasi
estático y lo que ya hemos visto y si yo
quiero ver cuál es el cambio en la
entropía bueno no tendría que preocupar
de poder por el calor que fue agregado y
las temperaturas no nos vamos a
preocupar diríamos ok qué hubiera pasado
si tomáramos un sistema reversible que
va de este mismo estado a este otro y
entonces como es reversible haría una
curva de esta forma ok
ahí está ya quedó mejor quizás en un
sistema reversible haría esto y este
cambio este cambio
digamos del calor reversible entre la
temperatura está bien definido porque es
un sistema reversible y ese si define un
cambio en la entropía y por lo tanto ese
sería una variable de estado por ejemplo
si tenemos una entropía final y una
entropía inicial cuando quiero calcular
el cambio en la entropía no me voy a ir
por el sistema irreversible no voy a ir
por esta curva en realidad voy a suponer
que fuera
un sistema reversible ok con la
temperatura constante y en cierto hasta
cierto punto esto es muy importante
porque no podemos definir la entropía
termodinámica más que de esta forma es
decir con el calor que agregamos en un
sistema reversible entre la temperatura
y quizás debí decir esto más claramente
en el vídeo anterior que toda esta
definición funcionó porque estábamos en
un ciclo de carnota que es un proceso
reversible